hey guys it's justine and in front of me
is the brand new nintendo switch this is
the oled version and i'm so excited
about this so a huge thank you to
nintendo for hooking me up with one of
these this thing has gone on a journey
so over the past couple of weeks i was
back visiting my family we rented a
cabin in maryland so i had it shipped
there but fedex for whatever reason
didn't deliver it on time i'd already
left that location but then they decided
to deliver it i was no longer there so
then i had to have the airbnb company
ship the switch all the way back to
california so this thing has gone all
across the united states over the past
couple of weeks it is finally here and i
could not be more excited normally i
play most of my video games over the
holidays so we are gearing up for video
game season and i can't wait for the new
animal crossing update that also means i
may or may not be live streaming on
twitch again so stay tuned for that well
let's open this up check it out ah
so beautiful like look at this
the white version looks so good we've
got our first joy-con controller
we've got our second joy-con controller
here it is oh boy this is so exciting
like the smile on my face it actually is
my face is hurting from smiling so much
look at that
[Applause]
look at this display look at this new
little kick stand
for the table top mode
yeah
this is a way better design than the
previous version that's for sure okay
continuing on we have the dock and the
all-new white color
look at that
this is nice nice little cut out there
for your cables
this is all new too check this oh man
i'm so excited about this we've even got
an ethernet cable for our local area
network and i like it the usb ports are
right there on the side now
[Music]
okay
now for the real test
it feels a little bit heavier
actually
not like significantly but like it feels
like it's got definitely some more
substance and weight to it oh
boy
it looks so good
uh yeah okay but
just for the sake of comparing
like this is that that's just that is a
huge difference this looks so great
oh you're giving me a tutorial i didn't
understand what was happening here okay
let me learn how to use this how to
transfer your animal crossing island
from one switch to another oh my
goodness you'll only be able to transfer
your animal crossing onto a new switch
in both the new switch and old switcher
present okay we've got that
so i have a lot of setup to do on this
new switch i'm currently downloading
mario kart animal crossing and i have
the island transfer tool on here and i
don't know if you guys can see up here
but you can tell already like there is
such a color difference this one is so
much more vibrant the screen is
obviously a lot larger i am about to hop
on a flight here very shortly and i
cannot wait to take this with me and
play on a plane that's how i played my
switch the most i mean i beat zelda on a
plane and i was all alone and i was like
celebrating in my seat and i was so
excited and like the person next to me
was just like cool okay good job and i
was like yeah i was like i just i just
beat the game and he's just like
are you an adult i'm like yep
sure
[Music]
so i've been playing with the oled
switch for the past couple of weeks now
and i am so obsessed i took it on a trip
recently and using this on the airplane
was so awesome it's so hard to even
explain how much better it is in the
previous version even my friend ed who
was a little bit suspect about getting
it because he didn't think it was going
to be that much of a difference after i
showed him the difference he's like okay
i need to get this immediately like it's
honestly so crisp so clear and having
the largest screen especially if this is
something that you do play handheld
you're going to notice the difference
right away i mean look at this mario
kart gameplay
oh my gosh it's so
smooth it's so much smoother than the
previous
[Music]
that was an impeccable shot
there's also something else that i just
recently ordered and they just came in
so i thought i would include it in this
video these are the controllers for
super nintendo we have the regular nes
and
hold on
the n64 controller what's exciting is
with nintendo online you can have access
to so many old school games and now you
can actually play these games with the
controllers that they were intended to
be played on how exciting like this is
so great i can't wait to play mario 64
using the nintendo 64 controller i can't
wait to play mario kart 64 i want to
play zelda i'm gonna play
all of the things that i possibly can
[Music]
this feels like my childhood
why i love nintendo 64 so much is
because i felt like i was a little bit
older so i actually really understood
video games so much more and this
controller is so iconic
oh
my
goodness
what a controller
so i'm going to dock my switch get this
all synced up and play a nintendo 64
game on my tv in 2021
[Music]
all right here we go i've got my n64
controller and we're about to hop in
here look at that oh what are we gonna
play all right let's play mario kart 64.
this oh my god the sound
this is seriously taking me back to my
childhood i freaking love it wow
just want to preface this by saying this
is an ak television
okay here we go
it's happening
this quality
is impeccable
[Applause]
[Music]
look at those blocks
okay power sliding
is
it's still a thing
this is where i learned a power slide
okay i gotta work on my controls a
little
i'm like trying to powerslide in all the
places that i used to when i was a child
[Music]
oh oh my god i'm so bad i'm so bad
if i don't come in first i'm going to be
very upset
this is a bunch of lies all right well
i'm definitely getting the hang of it
playing mario kart 64 on the actual
nintendo 64 controller it's pretty much
the coolest thing ever
wow thank you guys so much for watching
i'm so excited to keep playing the oled
switch it's been so much fun and it's
almost the holiday season which means i
will actually have time for video games
after this crazy tech season is over
hope you guys enjoyed this video and let
me know in the comments below what
you're most looking forward to coming
out this gaming season and i'll see you
guys in the next video bye
[Music]
you